i want to be a teacher okay that's
something i want to do it's amazing i
want to be like the best teacher my
father my mom they often tell me like
you're not going to make a lot of money
but i don't really care about making
money but like how do i like keep doing
what i want to do i'll be very honest
with you on some straight intuition [ __ ]
i don't think you're hearing them that
much just even the way you asked the
question i think you want to be
respectful to them it's gonna be your
life at the end anyway let me tell you
one thing about teaching or anything
else that doesn't make you [ __ ] a
million dollars a year the most upset
not happy people i know have the most
money that i know we need to start
changing conversation to happiness not
money you might not be in a position to
buy every new off-white on a teacher
salary but the question is do you need
that most people need it just to flex in
front of somebody because they're
insecure once you don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody's opinion you don't need
[ __ ] you ain't gonna buy anything you
need nothing